Asteria. My, Asteria wow it's a beautiful
name. It's from my culture how did you
do that it's just a simple shift of weight, takes
practice but i've been doing this a long time.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new wonder woman 3 video dc and warner
brothers just announced that they had fast tracked
the movie so i'll explain what's going on with
that what's going on with her during the justice
league snyder cut per zack snyder because that's
technically wonder woman's next movie that's
coming out in march and about all the crossovers
that people have talked about with the other
justice league characters because of when they're
going to put wonder woman 3 in the timeline
so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's going to
be a bunch of big dc movie stuff happening really
soon mostly because of the snyder cut because
that's the next big release that they have
we'll do a giveaway for hbo max subscriptions all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know what you want them to do with wonder woman
3 so if you didn't see the news this past weekend
dc and warner brothers just announced that because
the response they got the subscriber uptake in hbo
max was so strong they had fast tracked wonder
woman 3. they didn't report numbers but i think
they grew their subscriber base in the course of
a couple weeks by almost like 40 or 50 percent
and almost 60 percent of all hbo max subscribers
watched wonder woman 1984 within the first day
or so of it releasing on the platform last week
during christmas so even though the virus caused
this big theatrical shutdown and they didn't get
their big wide release so they wound up losing
a little bit of money they still accomplished
whatever their goal was just in terms of gaining
more subscribers for hbo max sidenote they also
announced that they have a new release strategy
they're going to be releasing four movies in
theaters starting in 2022 but also in addition
to that two movies to smaller more hardcore movies
exclusively on hbo max every year they didn't say
what all those movies are going to be but if you
remember the whole dc black label thing with the
joker movie that sounds like they would release
more movies like that on hbo max then do their
bigger more traditional huge movies in theaters
like the flash flashpoint movie or shazam 2 the
black adam movie aquaman 2 all those kinds of
movies the more traditional pg-13 family-friendly
movies but patty jenkins and gal gadot have spoken
a lot in the past few weeks about what their plans
are for the story of wonder woman 3. i think patty
jenkins has even been talking about wonder woman 3
for the past couple of years because wonder woman
1984 had been delayed for a while so the movie has
been done for a long time but the next movie is
a really good opportunity to course correct on
some of the bigger things most fans had issues
with during wonder woman 1984. one of the bigger
stylistic choices that i think a lot of people
were confused by is that if you watch wonder
woman 1984 it's meant to be as if they made
the movie during the 80s with 80s technology
but they're using modern day technology to pull
it off so the very spider-man looking way that
she swings around seems kind of weird or the way
she runs really fast the way they visualize that
look kind of weird but they did that on purpose
because they wanted it to look like it would have
looked if they would have done a wonder woman
movie during the 80s but i think a lot of people
just felt like it came off looking a little bit
weird and a little bit silly so i think when they
get to wonder woman 3 stylistically they'll try
to make it feel like a more traditional superhero
movie that you would expect to see in modern day
but they did announce that wonder woman 3 will
be set in present day probably the biggest change
from the last two movies which are period pieces
setting it in present day also as you guessed
allows them to do it as a crossover movie with
other big justice league characters which has
become the standard fare in big movie trilogies at
this point the whole thing with a trilogy is that
you have to escalate with each movie it has to get
bigger and bigger and bigger and sometimes the
only way to escalate things in that final movie
and change the formula with the last one is to add
a huge crossover character or do it as a team up
movie gal gadot was asked a bunch of questions
about crossovers during interviews last week
just in general just in the other dc movies would
you be showing up different places fans asked her
if she was going to appear in the black adam movie
because that's just the next dc movie that they're
getting ready to film with the rock she shares a
lot in common with the shazam characters both of
their power sets their mythology originate from
the greek pantheon of gods during wonder woman
1984 she talks about how there were many many gods
some of them evil some who create powerful magic
and items just to mess with humanity so it's only
natural that she would eventually cross over with
those characters but she claimed at least last
week when she was talking about it that she
wasn't planning on showing up in the black adam
movie specifically that she just wasn't ready to
do a movie as dark as that one right away they've
already announced the justice society and possible
henry cavill superman cameo for that movie so i
think part of the reason why she's also like no
i'm not going to be in the black adam movie is
because they kind of already have their plans
locked for who's going to be showing up during
that but they are filming shazam 2 almost at the
same time as the black adam movie and the tone of
that movie is actually going to be much closer to
the tone of the wonder woman movies zachary levi
has been talking for the last couple of years
about working all of his dark hollywood magic to
bend time and space and get wonder woman in the
movie so there's a solid chance that she and henry
cavill superman could cameo during shazam 2. it's
just that they'd also been hyping up a superman
crossover with the shazamly since the original
shazam post-credits scene within the universe per
this scene superman has already met the shazam
characters and at least billy batson has met a
good chunk of the justice league they didn't say
when they were going to try and release wonder
woman 3 they just said that they fast-tracked it
it probably wouldn't come before late 2022 at the
earliest and that's only if they start filming it
next year the star wars people you'll remember
just announced that patty jenkins was going to
do the next star wars movie called rogue squadron
and they already announced that the release date
for that is going to be christmas 2023 and patty
jenkins can't film two movies at the same time
none of the news outlets that are reporting this
wonder woman 3 news addressed that would the star
wars movie be delayed or would wonder woman 3
come out after that they say fast track so it
implies that they plan on releasing wonder woman
3 before the star wars movie but by the time they
will have released wonder woman 3 regardless of
whether it comes out before or after the star wars
movie she'll have already crossed over with the
shazam characters at least once possibly cameoed
in the flash flashpoint movie there are rumors
about that and maybe cameoed in aquaman 2 because
jason mamoa and pretty much every other justice
league character that's getting their solo movie
wants wonder woman to cross over with them so the
strongest pitches for the story of wonder woman 3
right now are one still do it as a standalone
movie not a huge crossover movie but you give
her a female villain who's also either a god or at
least as powerful as wonder woman so you solve the
big complaint of there not being enough action
scenes in wonder woman 1984 like her biggest
fight with the main antagonist maxwell lord was a
conversation and he wasn't even really that big of
a villain he was more of an antagonist right now
the best options for another major female villain
would be people like cersei who's another god a
lot of people have been talking about her for a
long time then you have other characters like
grail who's basically an evil version of the
wonder woman concept grail is the daughter of an
amazon woman and an evil god but it just happens
to be darkseid so she's the daughter of darkseid
like wonder woman is the daughter of zeus in an
amazon hippolyta so grail winds up being about
as powerful as wonder woman but she's not a full
god herself they do have a new gods movie that's
still supposed to be coming up at some point in
the future they haven't put a date on it yet
but grail is a bit of a stretch as a character
just because you kind of have to do a dark side
movie before you can do grail otherwise it's just
going to be confusing to people who don't read
those comics and don't already know who she is
number two you take the team up route and you
do wonder woman three as something like wonder
woman versus a character like black adam with
some of the shazam characters like billy batson
getting cameos because wonder woman shares a
lot in common with the black adam character
she's ancient just like black adam he's 5,000 plus
years old and why is black adam such an in present
day he only cares about strength power and getting
his dead wife and family back what did wonder
woman do for the first half of wonder woman 1984
pine over steve trevor being dead then go crazy
when she did bring him back with her wish she
accomplished what black adam has been trying to
do the whole time since he came out of his magical
prison that'll all play out during the black adam
movie if you're not really familiar with that
character so she just has some common ground that
she can speak with him on like look i get it i do
you want your loved ones back but you need to move
on with your life and one of his trademark special
moves is throwing magical lightning bolts and she
can soak those pretty easily i don't know if she's
ever actually been able to call lightning herself
but during wonder woman 1984 she started to
replicate some of the other more complex abilities
that zeus had like making things invisible without
having to spell cast like she can kind of cast
spells a little bit use magical abilities
without having to speak the words of a spell
so visually their fights would be pretty cool
but most people seem to want a female villain
for wonder woman three the number three regardless
of who they decide the main villain is going to be
or what the story is they should bring back linda
carter's asteria character they hyped her up so
much in that post-credits scene she's supposed
to be their greatest warrior and she's still out
running around the world saving people while this
is all going on zack snyder said that wonder woman
during the justice league snyder cut is going to
get some crazy crazy fight scenes so if you're
looking for more traditional superhero fare from
the wonder woman character we're gonna get that
with the justice league snyder cut of course i'll
be doing videos for all that stuff zack snyder
also said that he was gonna try and get a limited
imax theatrical release because the entire movie
was filmed in imax ratio that big square true imax
ratio he did say that there would be a new justice
league snyder cut trailer sometime late january
i believe he did say they start making more noise
about that in 2021 so they'll start promoting that
in earnest you'll start seeing a lot more footage
there's also a bunch of upcoming disney plus
marvel shows that i'll be doing videos for every
week as well so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
when i post them everyone click here to watch that
wonder woman 1984 post credit scene in easter eggs
and click here for all the mandalorian star wars
ahsoka tano special bonus scenes and footage
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!